hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by
squarespace and i will be reviewing
another harper's bazaar
what i eat in a day by infamous
supermodel tyra banks
now before we get into it i wanted to
chat about my sponsor
squarespace so if you're not familiar
squarespace is an all-in-one platform
where you can build a website blog
online store
or just use their marketing tools and
analytics they have so many new awesome
features that are perfect for new
entrepreneurs and hobbyists
who are looking to get their passion out
into the world
so for example if you want to blog they
have an easy integrated
commenting system and blogging tools for
sharing and scheduling posts
if you are super into your instagram or
facebook you can sync
those up with your website to make sure
that everything is working together
nicely
they also have all of your analytics
there so that you can see
how your site is performing and adjust
your content strategy based on your
stats
honestly i wish this kind of support was
available when i was
just starting on blogging like a decade
ago because it would have saved me
so much money and time but if you're
interested in getting started
you can check out squarespace.com for a
free trial
and when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com
slash abby sharp to save 10 off of your
first purchase of a website or domain
also super quick before we dive in you
can pause this screen
or look in the description to check out
my disclaimer including a
trigger warning to those with current or
previous experiences with disordered
eating
i will be evaluating meals based on
their nutritional merit alone which says
very little
about their overall value so if that's
not supporting
your food journey by all means sit this
one out
and of course don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that little bell
so that you never miss out on a video
all right let's hear from tyra i love
me some coffee and i like my coffee with
a little bit of flavor in it i just mean
the
beans have been soaked in some vanilla
or some caramel infusation is that a
word
and so i make my coffee black
no sugar no cream just my infused flavor
so here's a juicy little topic to kick
off the video
flavored coffee if you have a sweet
tooth and you're trying to cut back on
the added sugars
syrups and like flavored creamers and
things like that you might be into
buying
like creme brulee or birthday cake or
pumpkin spice coffee beans
typically the nutrition label doesn't
list any extra calories so
what the heck is in them to give them
that flavor well
believe it or not but flavored coffee
beans are often made with
lower quality or older coffee beans that
then get sprayed with
natural and often synthetic flavorings
as well as being
bathed in solvents like alcohol
propylene glycol
and vegetable oils which help to get the
flavor to adhere
sometimes if you're buying it pre-ground
the flavor is kind of added
in like a starch-based powder right into
the coffee ground
does that mean they are toxic no does
that mean that they are
bad for you no if you love the taste of
bananas foster coffee
then you do you but i will say a lot of
coffee connoisseurs are
understandably anti-flavored beans
because
they see it as a way of selling
semi-stale or like poor quality beans
and masking the true flavor of something
that they love but if you don't love the
flavor of
coffee then brew up that chocolate
caramel brownie coffee
and you do you i'm just gonna take a sip
here of my
coffee flavored coffee
all right let's see what she's having to
eat i take my bagel
then i take my whipped cream cheese
and i put it inside of the microwave
whoa so i have to blow and then i
slowly bring it to my mouth and i try to
get the cleanest bite
but there's whipped cream whatever cream
all
over my lips that was
that description of a bagel was the
textbook
definition of extra you would think that
this is like an audition tape
for cats but anyways let's talk about
the bagel
well not to be a [ __ ] but much like
tyra's current hollywood status
i feel like this breakfast is a little
passe
like hello 2010 called and it wants its
low-carb breakfast hack back
just kidding i am admittedly a little
salty because of the blackface
controversy which
forever put a real bad taste in my mouth
but okay there's nothing wrong with a
classic bagel and cream cheese sami
especially if it's an everything bagel
which you know is my jam but i gotta say
there isn't a whole lot of nutrition
going on to hold her
until lunch first of all to hollow or
not hollow to be or not to be that is
the question
tyra you are giving me thespian energy
here
listen if you're watching your carbs or
like you're just
not that excited by the inside of your
bagel
it's worth pointing out that a standard
bakery bagel
does contain twice the carbs and
calories of two slices of whole grain
bread
so you could literally have four slices
of bread and get four times the fiber
and more protein if you went the whole
grain bread root
having said that you sometimes just
can't replace
a good bagel and for some myself
included
hollowing it out kind of ruins
the bagel eating experience bubby would
not approve
so if that is true for you you might
just be better off from an enjoyment
and nutrition standpoint to choose a
good
quality bread instead as for the
microwave changing the molecular
structure of the cheese
tire girl if you are good at one thing
it's making things
seem way more complicated and pompous
than needs be the microwave might melt
the cream cheese a little
it may slightly alter your perception of
the flavor
but it's still just basic ass cream
cheese
so if i was going to make any
suggestions here it would be to swap the
hollowed out bagel for a few slices of
whole grain bread
or at least choose a whole grain bagel
for a little extra fiber
and then i would go half seas on the
cream cheese
and split the difference with some
avocado for healthy fats
some sliced hard boiled egg for some
protein
and then load it up with some extra
veggies honestly
if there was ever a good reason to
hollow out the innards of a bagel
it would be to fit more veggies and
protein
between the halves so that you can fit
more
not less nutrition into your mouth
so i go into our snack box do i want
corn chip
or do i want sesame bar or do i want
some
and i feel disgusting and this my
friends
is the problem with all of these health
food snacks
i bring you the classic flavor hunt
let's say you really want ruffles potato
chips with all
the salt but you tell yourself nah that
stuff is bad
so you open up a bag of cauliflower
puffs instead
obviously that wasn't what you wanted so
you go for the bean chips
nope not that let's have the natural
licorice
then the sesame bar then the corn chips
until finally you say
and you blast through a family-sized bag
of the ruffles that you should have
probably just eaten a modest bowl of
in the first place nls here you are
like tyra said with nine open bags in
front of you
and maybe not feeling so hot now tyra
may genuinely like all of these
healthier snacks
but in my experience when you feel the
need to graze through
a wide range of foods until you feel
disgusting as she said there's probably
a sense of mental scarcity
still going on it's generally always a
better idea to allow yourself
mind proportions of the real deal and
just move on
as for these snacks i want to also just
say that there's nothing wrong with any
of them
if they spark joy but don't be fooled by
the health halo
that some of them possess natural
licorice for example
whatever the hell that means still has
like
16 grams of added sugar per serving and
nothing really else
so if you enjoy these snacks amazing
like i actually have the cauliflower
puffs at home and i think they're pretty
good
but remember what i always say about
eating naked carbs
rather than thinking about cutting them
out we want to think about what we can
add in to make it a more satiating
balanced snack so i would suggest
pairing one of these chips or crisps
maybe with some higher fat or higher
protein dips like hummus
or a black bean dip or guacamole which
let's be real would just make this whole
thing
way tastier as well i have a very
interesting relationship with food a lot
of my
personal life and the things that i like
to do and my hobby
is food so much so that right now
you can't tell because i have on a men's
blazer
i am 25 pounds heavier
than i was on the cover of a very famous
swimsuit magazine that came out last
year so i'm
30 pounds heavier and
it'll come off one day but
not today so i am super
curious what tyra defines as being
interesting about
her relationship with food obviously i
can't tell that much just from this
quick little six minute interview
i am happy to hear that she doesn't seem
too distraught or alarmed by her recent
weight gain
and she continues on the conversation
talking about
her apparent love of food i mean i feel
like this is a situation
a lot of us have found ourselves in in
covet times and
i'm sure it's somewhat reassuring to
your supermodel normalizing the
experience
and practicing some compassion or
you know at least not making it a thing
i'm sure it's not easy to
turn off that part of your brain when
body manipulation has been
so heavily ingrained in your life and
career
and i also hope that she now looks back
on some of her body shaming remarks on
america's next top model
and feels embarrassed that she
participated
and perpetuated that problematic culture
most notably
this disgusting comment right here
danielle you went to the dentist but you
refused to have your gap closed do you
really think you can have a covergirl
contract with the gap in your mouth
yes why not this is all people say it's
easy beautiful color girl
anyways let's focus on the food abby
focus
on the food let's hear what she has to
say i go to a delivery app
and i choose two different restaurants
with the same cuisine let's say
mexican laranja i will order nachos
i will order nachos from burrito
i'll order one here and then they come
almost at the same time
and then there's the taste test so that
sounds like a really fun game and also a
good way to narrow down the sea of
options
on your ubereats app having said that
obviously this is a privileged exercise
that could cost you
double in delivery fees so you can also
just start like a little restaurant
journal where you take
notes of the dishes that you ordered and
what you liked
and didn't like that way when you go to
order again
you know where your money is best spent
anyway if you want to see
what i order and how i order when i get
delivery or takeout
you can check out my vlog video right
here one thing that i recently cooked
is my sriracha maple bacon
jerky candied yum i take
bacon and i create a sauce on the side
that is
maple syrup but it has to be fake maple
syrup not that fancy canadians
okay i'm here for the bacon girl but
what
the hell is fake maple syrup i mean i
know what it is
but i didn't know that somebody
actively would choose pancake syrup
over the real deal honestly i am way
less concerned with the fact that
pancake syrup is fake or
not clean or is made with high fructose
corn syrup then i am legit just offended
that anyone would try to mess with our
national
treasure do not [ __ ] with the canadian
and her syrup
but since we're on the topic and it
doesn't look like tyra's eating anything
else for dinner let me talk about the
deal with high fructose corn syrup found
in products
like pancake syrup so you probably heard
high fructose corn syrup described by
wellness alarmists
of all as in our world i mean
it's not great for you but i think we
can like
take it down a titch and calm the f
down so basically this is an inexpensive
sweetener found in a lot of commercial
drinks and
snack foods that's made from corn and it
has a higher proportion of fructose
to glucose than regular corn syrup or
table sugar
the reason it's been so heavily
scrutinized in the media
is that we do have a fair bit of
research to suggest that consuming
excess fructose increases fatty liver
insulin resistance high cholesterol and
visceral fat
more so than glucose consumption
fructose consumption
also seems to not affect the areas of
the brain controlling appetite
the same way that glucose does which may
explain its relationship with weight
gain
and obesity having said all of that
while i do think it's wise to keep tabs
on your intake of high fructose corn
syrup
if you're eating a balanced diet that's
generally low in added sugars the
relative proportion of calories from
high fructose corn syrup won't likely be
a big deal i would rather people think
about limiting
overall added sugar consumption to the
recommended
10 of calories or less then i would
suggest
obsessing over getting that sugar from
allegedly healthy
or clean options like honey or maple
syrup
instead of toxic sources like high
fructose corn syrup
hey if you love the taste of aunt
jemima's
as it seems tyra does then cool
like enjoy your candy bacon slathered in
the stuff
but focus on choosing a sugar you
actually love
and making that sugar count rather than
thinking that there's like a massive
health difference to your health
depending
on the source there is a difference yes
but
don't lose sight of the forest from the
trees total
intake is much more important as for the
maple sriracha bacon
jerky yum that i can't deny
sounds legit amazing like it obviously
takes
all the sensory boxes so it's something
that obviously probably would taste
really good
now i don't need to tell you that it's a
high salt high sugar
high fat recipe but i also assume that
this recipe is not meant to replace
a meal but rather it might just be like
a fun little garnish for something else
i've seen spicy maple bacon adorned
dessert
or like a caesar cocktail which by the
way is the better canadian version of a
bloody mary
so again i don't think it's meant to be
a health food
or to be served all on its own it's just
meant to taste
really freaking good i personally think
it would be
amazing on like a nutrient dense salad
to add
a huge pop of flavor and texture so if a
little sweet and spicy bacon helps you
make friends with salad i say amen
to that all right what can we say about
miss tyra's meals
or i guess not so much meals as like a
meal
and some snacks i think we could
definitely stand to add in
like a vegetable or a piece of fruit
somewhere in here and no the cauliflower
puffs
do not count but i will just say that i
was so relieved to not have to wade
through
a bunch of pseudoscience wellness tips
from such
a high profile supermodel who lives and
breathes in such a diet culture heavy
industry
so while i am a little bit still bitter
about tyra's grossly problematic
america's next top model past
i'm at least reassured by not also
getting force-fed a lot of woo
in this interview so thank you tyra now
on that note
friends that is all that we have for
today thank you again to squarespace for
sponsoring this video
if you liked it be sure to subscribe to
the channel leave me a comment below
with your thoughts on who you'd like to
see me review next
subscribe to the channel and i will see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye